hey guys I'm back for a short video to
show you the fastest way to get rid of
your back fat and these are the most
important things can you take awhile
guess what you're gonna do fast okay
fasting hands down is the most powerful
tool to get rid of very resistant
stubborn fat especially on your back now
there's three types of fat you have the
fat in your liver you have a fat in the
visceral area around the abdomen okay
then you have what's called a
subcutaneous fat and that is the fat
that's superficial right underneath the
skin so that is the pizza crust that you
might have on the front that wraps right
around the back now this is the first
thing to go away then this and lastly
this right here and this is why it's
frustrating for some people that's work
so hard and they still are not able to
get rid of this back fat but I'm gonna
show you how to do it so realize that
fasting will actually increase your
metabolism fasting will normalize
insulin and insulin resistance so if you
have a stubborn metabolism over time
fasting will correct it so if we took
the ketogenic diet and you just did this
okay and you did not fast you may not
ever get rid of your back fat or even
the fat around your lower part of your
stomach and it really depends on the
frequency of your meal so if you're
doing snacks between the meal but it's
still keto you still may have a problem
especially if you have a slow metabolism
now some people will be able to lose
that extra fat but most people will not
so if we compare keto with them fasting
and fasting is actually more important
however if you combine them you'll have
even better results so I'm gonna assume
that you're doing keto
that being said 80% of the population if
they did fasting for 18 hours would be
able to get rid of their back that over
a period of time so let's say for
example they skip their breakfast their
first meal is at 12:00 and their second
meal at 6 that will give you an 18 hour
window so this should work for the
majority of the population
ever if you're the 20% then it doesn't
work on you're gonna have to go to 20
hours up to 23 hours okay so 23 hours
would give you like a 1 hour of eating
that's called ohm at one meal a day okay
but between 20 hours and 23 hours so
let's say for example you skipped
breakfast lunch and you ate at 3 o'clock
and then you next meal it was at 7
o'clock right here that is a 4 hour
window and that will give you 20 hours
of fasting that would be very very
powerful yet some people need to take it
to the next level
and fast all the way to this one meal a
day which could be at 6 it could be at 5
it could be at 7 it could be 8 it
doesn't really matter it just matters
that you fast for 23 hours ok and you
will lose the fat in the liver first
visceral fat and then subcutaneous fat
realize this won't go away unless you
get rid of the fat around the liver so
you might not see anything visibly for a
bit but it's happening just give it some
time
just have patience that's why we call
you a patient and we put you in the
waiting room now what are you gonna be
consuming when you're not eating well
you can do some tea you can do some
coffee I would recommend just a little
tiny bit of cream okay not too much I
would also recommend because you're
going to be eliminating a lot of fluid
and electrolytes to add the electrolytes
back in and some B vitamins to
nutritional yeast I would also recommend
some apple cider vinegar that would
speed things up with some lemon juice
you can do real lemons and roughly about
2 litres of fluid especially when you're
starting out because you're going to
lose a lot of fluid and don't forget a
little bit of sea salt will be very very
beneficial and lastly there's just a
couple other things you can do to speed
things up you can start bringing your
carbs down below 10 grams I'm gonna put
a link down below of a video that I did
entitled keto on steroids okay so that
will actually help you understand what
this means right here and then you can
add exercise now you would think
exercise would be the most
thing it's the least important thing you
see people at the gym all the time that
are working out like crazy and they they
all have the pizza crust that's because
they're having the workout drink which
is all sugary or the exercise protein
bar before during and after they workout
and they're just filling themselves up
with carbs so exercise typically will
give you like fifteen percent of the
results and that's not consuming any
carbs because the carbs that you eat
will nullify the exercise results
however if you combine the fasting with
keto and then add some exercise in here
and ideally you would add in a pretty
hardcore workout maybe a couple times a
week a full body workout we're using
multiple muscle groups cuts called
compound resistance that would be really
really important but just make sure you
don't over train because that will slow
down your progress I've had people work
out I'm not kidding six hours a day
daily yeah no weight loss they're
overtraining and the last thing I would
do if if you're doing everything and
it's just still not happening you may
need to cut down your fat to about 70
grams simply because we want to force
your body to burn and live off your own
fat not the dietary fat as much you
don't want to go low-fat but seventy
grams would be perfect alright go ahead
and try this and then put your comments
down below thanks for watching so I'm
back with a quick video to show you the
absolute fastest way to get rid woops
just oh my gosh so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications